you know how we were talking about like
a few weeks ago how like in like 10
years we're going to be laughing at
[ __ ] bass boosted braille like morse
code memes or something so like i think
i've already reached that point because
i was i was watching a meme the other
day and the meme is just like called
gamers in 2030 and it was just
it's already funny
and i was just
it was just that scene from wally
right with like the kids on like the
tricycles or whatever and it was just
them looking at sorting algorithms
i don't know why it was so funny
it was just it was just
sorting algorithm and fart noise
i feel like i have to see this
my sense of humor is so most certainly
one of those memes that is [ __ ] awful
explaining yeah god i can't explain why
i think it's funny
i just i think i think i was just like i
was more laughing at the fact that i
found this funny or it was just like a
[ __ ] laugh loop
just kept building a lot
i literally can't explain the science of
why i found this funny because it's
[ __ ] it makes it makes absolutely
zero sense yeah
speaking of memes you know what i
recently invested in what let me show
you boys
oh yeah oh yeah yeah i saw that i got
the goku drip jacket how much was that
you don't want to know yeah you don't
want it
really
so i i was it official yeah
oh okay
so so i think it's it's estimated value
is like
estimated value yeah the same way that
like nfts are worth value yeah yeah yeah
it's like i think two and a half grand
right i managed to found it on uh yahoo
auction or some [ __ ] right
for like a grand where it was like it
was like
ripped and torn and they showed a
picture of it and this japanese standard
of ripped and torn on the sleeve it's
like a tiny bit ripped instead and so
obviously they'd like gutted the price
because of that and i was like bro i'll
take that
for a meme i don't need it not gonna lie
the jacket's kind of sick
i bought it specifically for a meme with
a video that will come out at some point
yeah like i i i i was like i'm gonna
wear this maybe i'm probably gonna wear
it much probably just get it for the
beam then i might wear it outside but
now i'm like okay you need to wear it
out i kind of like this
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] sick finally
something to rival the jojo's
somebody says i i i don't have drip i
just threw money at the problem money
made it go don't even think about
fashion i literally bought the
definition of drip i bought the goku
jacket
i i was gonna get the supreme shirt as
well but [ __ ] that knock
at least there's a north face coat yeah
so at least it's a decent coat yeah but
i mean still it's way overpriced what it
is though jesus it's north face though
it felt very high quality though but not
a thousand dollars
you're gonna wear that like when you go
to like snowboarding
oh dude imagine snowballing again yeah
that's what i'm thinking that's what i'm
thinking man
i'd be so scared to like rip it or fall
on it though because like dude what if i
[ __ ] if i rip that jacket though that's
the most expensive [ __ ] piece of
clothing i've ever bought in my life
yeah that's insane
well
like what was i gonna say like going
back to your yahoo auction thing yeah
i've just noticed that whenever like a
japanese person goes like they say on
their second-hand store that it is like
bad quality always like a little ripped
a little something it's it's not at all
yeah it's basically new because i had a
similar experience because i just
recently bought um a gilgamesh watch so
you know how we have like the jojo
watching so they recently uh they before
that they did a collaboration with um
with you know fates and fake characters
so i bought the gilgamesh one and it was
like really really discounted because on
the website it said um scratches and
dents right and i'm just like and i'm
just like okay whatever i just i just
want it because it's a gilgamesh
so i get it and the scratches and dents
which was like one little dent on the
corner of the box and one scratch on the
[ __ ] box itself yeah right that's
what that's what put its price down it's
it's it's not even on the watch itself
it was on like it was on like the
packaging which i'm not even going to
show off anyway right
japanese secondhand is not secondhand
it's like 1.5 hands yeah yeah yeah it's
weird because some websites uh there's
other websites like medicare yeah that
have ratings yeah and like it'll be like
triple a which literally means that it
is probably better than the [ __ ]
factory quality yeah yeah
it's literally like insane yeah a a is
like very good like a store quality um
you know and then a a just normal a is
like good like i've bought so i think
the jacket was listed like a b or
something right and i was or like ba
yeah or something sync b yeah and then
it was like it was fine it's literally
fine yeah but it was like and it was
like stained but i looked at it i
couldn't even [ __ ] find the stain
that was in the photo so i don't
understand what what's happened yeah i i
used mirokari once to get uh like that
crt tv yeah oh yeah and like
[ __ ] it like okay so i bought that for
300 bucks yeah right which i was like
okay you know what decent decent oh yeah
turns out later i found out like
normally for good condition that thing
is usually like five grand oh my god and
the only reason it was 300 bucks is
because
it was owned by a dude who took perfect
care of it wow and i was like
what why you could have easily extorted
me for a couple of grand at least for
this yeah yeah there was like 300 people
japan is one of the only countries where
i think a lot of stuff you can just like
just get it secondhand like you don't
really need to worry about it like don't
yeah clothes i've noticed online are
like insane conditions somehow i don't
understand how i wear an angle of
clothing once and it i look [ __ ] it
looks like yeah like like
i wash it once and i'm just like this is
a wash clothes i can feel it i can see
it i don't understand like i i i don't
know what i'm doing wrong maybe maybe
i'm just like a neanderthal with my
caveman machine i suppose even when you
go to like book off right and you know
you go to like the second hand clothing
sections and it's like this is clearly
like old clothing and it's been slashed
down but you look at it it's like
yeah what's wrong with it
also video game consoles oh yeah yeah
dude it is insane how easy it is to get
like nintendo 64 games in box for less
than ten dollars yeah yeah like you see
super mario 64 in box everywhere yeah
and it's like 500 yen it's like five
dollars for an inbox copy of super mario
yeah i've i've got one and it's paying
like 700 yen it's insane
it's actually insane like and you can
get the nintendo 64s in box
for like 20 yeah i got mine for like 30.
it's it's it's absurd like and it's
actually stupid the only consoles that
are expensive are stuff like the neo geo
um and some sega saturn is usually some
of the sega ones yeah but like nes snes
there's so many of them in box and and
so many of them outside of the box you
can just get like a plastic bag yeah
with a perfect condition n64 or an nes
or snes for like ten dollars it's insane
and you can get like the [ __ ] uh
limited edition game cubes for cheap i
know they like the orange one is that i
got the orange yeah yeah that's like 60
bucks 80 bucks basically like japan is
just a collector's dream because there
are so many like rare items that you can
find here
for like mint condition like it's it's
actually insane how good they take care
of their stuff like i opened something
out of the box somehow i get a scratch
on it immediately
exactly right
like my hands touch it and it just like
i leave some kind of mark on it i don't
know how it's possible so i don't know
how these like how these guys are taking
care of these mint condition
everything every every item is so
careful with stuff here yeah yeah i you
know i i'm not saying i'm reckless i'm
not [ __ ] throwing them everywhere no
but i think they go to an extreme level
of care yeah to make sure everything is
perfect and it's kept proper because
like even the books right even the books
you buy a book off or something normally
when i when i read a book you get like
the natural bends with it right somehow
the books are like just perfectly
straight like mint condition a lot of
the times how how are you doing this are
you like reading it with a tweezer are
you like
is this like is this like a csi crime
scene or something where they're just
looking on the gloves they open it for a
second take a picture of the phone and
they read it on the phone
i can't i can't increase it
i can't expose the paper to oxygen
yeah it's actually insane yeah i don't
know
i don't know like how they got this kind
of culture around them but that's good
for us because we can find so many
things here you know find some rare
items here get a cheap cheaper drip
jacket for a ridiculous price i think i
think it's because in japan especially
it's like the whole idea of like not so
much recycling but i guess like the
whole idea of oh if i move or you know
something happens or if i run out of
money then like i'm gonna have to like
resell this [ __ ] so i think a lot of
people just buy it naturally to just
with the intent to resell it yeah
because like i feel like you use it or
not yeah i feel like resell culture at
least outside it's just to me to me it
was like never worth the time investment
to try and resell something unless
unless i knew i owned something that was
like super super valuable like most
everyday stuff i'm just like i don't
yeah most of the time you just throw it
out yeah exactly it's it's more it's
more effort to sell for example maybe
you'll use clothes i think it's because
it's such a [ __ ] pain in the ass to
throw anything out here in japan yeah
like like into like trash yeah and also
you have to like pay for anything even
remotely big yeah exactly anything
bigger than like 40 centimeters yeah so
it's like why would i pay to get rid of
this thing when i could just resell it
and make money to get rid of it yeah and
also when you want to throw something
away in japan you have to book when you
want to throw it yeah yeah and it takes
like a month yeah yeah so when i uh when
i was in my old place i bought uh the
toilet but in the new place there was
already one installed so i didn't need
the the bidet sorry yeah um so i had to
throw it away and i had to wait two
months to throw it away yeah so just in
my apartment just collecting dust for
two months before i throw it away isn't
this insane two months i had that with
my uh like desk as well and everything
like tables and everything it's like oh
cool 40 days from now i can throw this
throw out this piece of [ __ ] i don't
need anymore oh in uk you just stick it
on gumtree for free and someone would
come around and take it mm-hmm i mean
this size like that in japan as well
they're just not like really readily
available like almost like known about
yeah and also probably not the best for
like foreigners if you can't read
japanese yeah i guess you probably you
could probably make it work with like
google translate oh yeah yeah but you
know you can probably do it on like
middle cutting and stuff like that right
that's probably why it's so
so popular yeah true and true yeah i
i've realized now that a lot of websites
can be
figured out
once you just you know you you have
google translate or whatever and like
most of them work exactly the same way
as most websites work so you know it's a
big deterrent because once the rest of
the world figure it out i'm sure people
can be buying like way cooler [ __ ] but
but now it's like we have all the access
to it so uh yeah might as well use it
well yeah i mean a lot of the sites are
popping up with prop proxy shipping so
yeah
on the podcast so yeah i mean a lot of
the time you are getting a [ __ ] steal
yeah i think the hardest one actually is
just yahoo auction yahoo auction it's
like i know the language and i still
don't know i
like some kind of weird like simon says
which panel to click on for which there
because it's not like amazon we can just
like oh bye yeah right it's like you
have to like bit it's not bidding it's
not you you bid you bid but there is
also buy now so it's like ebay it's just
literally ebay right but there's an
etiquette and this is where i [ __ ] up
because now my account is poorly
reviewed because i didn't reply saying i
got the item yeah
oh yeah i just you know i assumed that
he got the confirmation the package had
been sent yeah and so he wrote like a
really angry passive aggressive review
in google translate that why
asking why i didn't [ __ ] say i got it
right and i was like i don't think it's
that big of a deal is it i mean i'm sure
i didn't reply it's all good right yeah
you did your job i paid you the money
and it's fine because he gets the money
immediately so yeah so you think that if
you got the money then that means it
arrives safely yeah yeah yeah and also
it was weird because you can't use a
normal email for yahoo
i don't have anything notifications set
up so i didn't see it so but i i got my
jojo figure so i don't care i got my
jojo figure is that the only thing you
bought of yahoo auction
thing right oh no that's miraculous oh